this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes t.c
Columbia edu
oh it would have been sweet mysteries of
life okay thank you sweet mysteries of
life is what I call diabetes mellitus
because you know one of the things is is
that I'll go from place to place in and
there will be times when I'll see my
clients at some place where they were
eating at and you'll see their plate and
then you'll see on the side of their
plate you'll see this thing called
observe sugar and they'll say Oh dr. boo
I'm here and I'll say well that's all
you still diabetes become sweetness to
your life this protocol was developed
due to a program and a great that we got
from Kaiser Permanente and consumer
Health Foundation over five year period
we do natural medicine so we went
looking for the nutritional deficiencies
associated with diabetes mellitus some
of these slides I made I may just omit
let me see where we are here okay now
one of the things is is that did you
know that the Egyptians had diabetes now
most people know the Egyptians have
diabetes and it's real interesting what
they use to to get rid of diabetes I
don't I don't recommend this for people
from one of the the items that they use
was beer and if you understand beer and
you understand the hops in beer hops
helps to rebalance blood sugar level
like oats does then they use water from
the bird bran I definitely wouldn't
record
and then they used flower blossom flower
blossom is a herb that we use that's a
Chinese herb those are the things that
they use in terms to rebalancing it and
then the word was coined in 1808 1880
that's the first time they uses the word
diabetes which basically meant sweet
urine now statistics is wrong that
should be twenty twenty three point six
million people are affected but the
thing is is that by 2025 there will be
three million people worldwide with
diabetes that's a lot of people and and
if we we look at that and understand
that what we're looking at is is that
that's our children and I bring the
children and maybe even they sure
so so diabetes is really going to be
devastating during that point the other
that the other thing is is that when we
look at type 2 diabetes as its previous
say we're finding that children
beginning at age two are beginning to
establish type of type 2 diabetes which
at one point it was type of one and one
of the things that's linked to type 1
diabetes is cow's milk there's a fitness
study that talks about that and George
Washington University did a piece on it
that talks about the fact
type 1 is all cow stuff is also
connected to the inner ear infections
that children get along with the
constipation let's talk about the making
of diabetes may be the making of
diabetes has to do with several
different things let me ask this
question here first up how many chemists
do I have a row there's no chemists in
the room nobody's at chemists come on
one person has to be a chemist
nobody ladies and gentlemen I hate to
tell you we all chemists
every time you put something your mouth
you dealing with chemistry start to
bring it down in your mouth
protein break it down in the stomach
that's all about chemistry diabetes is
about chemistry it's about chemistry of
the digest just subtract so what we
start looking at it we start looking at
the fact that is that last one okay
we start looking at that the chemical
imbalances of enzymes because enzymes if
you don't have enzymes as well as you
know you we won't be around improving
food consumption you know we have to get
rid of to be seafoods lack of you treat
nutrients in the foods we we eat so many
overcooked and processed foods that
effect is a thing called Allison Allison
is what is given to rats in clinical
trial studies to cause diabetes well
let's say element is in white flour so
once once the flowers bleach and all the
nutrients is taken out of it you wind up
with others and then we have the
environment
of course I mean you know we were
talking about the pollution you can't go
anyplace without the pollution lack of
proper digestion now how many people in
here really chew your food okay
you see we live in a godless society
- right sin is gone when you knew that
you don't give the food chance enough to
digest so that you can get the nutrients
from them so that's another factor
that's going to call it cause it and
then we talk about viral viral
infections most we have to do with type
1 diabetes these are the nutrients that
are scientifically found to cause
diabetes these diabetic has one or
multiple of these different different
elements fiza's chromium chromium and
chromium picolinate is one of the pieces
that that absolutely gets rid of
diabetes my surrogate mother called me
last week week before last and her blood
sugar was off the chart I I suggested
her taking two different two of these
elements one is magnesium and the other
horse chromium within within three days
time her blood sugar levels came down
below 90 her doctor was amazed we're
suffering from malnutrition
that's what diabetes is our program had
proved a factor that that when you give
people the nutrients that they need what
begins to happen
is that their blood sugar levels begin
to balance when you teach them how to
eat that's it they they begin to to to
balance the research the goals to
provide to prevent reduce and will
eliminate the prevalence of diabetes
obesity hypertension and high
cholesterol influences educate the
community to increase the nutritional
value we do not we do not when we walked
into a room the first thing I tell
people is that I am NOT here to change
anything in your life I am here to give
you some information you take that
information and do what you will with it
my job is to inform you and educate you
and that's exactly what I do then we
introduce the community to help it
lifestyle changes some people change
others don't prevent the prevalence of
the disease of chronic disease increase
physical activity amongst families not
just children in our program one of the
interesting things about our programs
which a funders could not could not
understand is the factor that we would
wind up having more people people would
join the process it's a 12 is a 12 we
process people would want to join in the
process opposed to people leave in the
process we provide a healthy lifestyle
workshops introduce participants to the
dynamics of good and healthy nutrition
we promoted non life changes introduced
physical activity and trained
participants to present healthy
lifestyle workshops in their communities
I evaluation process we did a a post mid
in a pre post in
mid evaluation where people's
self-reported there's a form that it is
a booklet that I give people that has
them to calculate their blood sugar
levels what they eat on a daily basis
that has a graphic chart and all of that
because the thing is is to get them to
be responsible to take back their own
health and so we gave them that the
monthly the chart I was talking about
and this is the program we met for 12
weeks for two hours once a week we
weighed people we took their blood
pressure we then went into physical
activity we did that for 30 minutes we
went into the progressive relaxation we
then had a healthy lecture we had a
healthy meal and we followed up with
them on three and six-month basis and
the interesting thing was that we had
children there we had children from
actually the age of three years old - I
think that oldest was about 12 years old
and the children asked some very
interesting questions that that actually
made their personal get them acidic now
we do get that from because of the fact
that the children you know a children to
ask four questions in 10 adults I mean
and they asked all kinds of questions
but in the process of doing that like I
said we began to to increase the people
this was a baseline I based I was a
seven-year over seven years
we saw 1009 actually was 1200 after we
wouldn't recalculated some things and
they were from age 20 to 65 but they had
their children whatever we we helped the
program four times again in other words
we moved the program program around the
community we moved the program every 12
weeks every three months we were in a
different location with the program and
and the interesting thing was that
people from the previous program would
come to the program to the new program
and as they came to the new program they
would then begin to volunteer to assist
us in doing the program participants
were insulin dependent most of them were
type 2 we did have a few that were type
1 diabetics and several of them were
taking pharmaceuticals we didn't we
didn't tell people to stop taking any
medicines or anything in that nature and
we had a lot of help with with their
physicians because as whoops go back
okay is that right
okay so the physical activity was
achieved on with now use a yoga and she
come and she called if you don't know
it's an ancient Chinese exercise that
aids in any blood flowing it aids in
getting the Chi is we call it or the
energy flowing and I go back to China to
study every three years and so in China
when I'm studying we go to a hospital
whether you
nothing but she come on things like
diabetes matter of fact when I was in
Cuba we did a thing where where we use
another art that I use which is called
29 which is traditional Chinese bodywork
and we use it in Cuba for diabetics and
we found it to actually really assist in
lowering blood sugar levels then
physical movement and some of the
physical movement was just yet just bad
physical movement we do all kinds of
things we had a good time and then
rhythmatic breathing to get to breathing
because when you when you hit them when
you get the oxygenate the blood the
blood then begins to change from a city
to alkaline and so as we oxygenated the
blood we gotta cut to become more
alkaline and it also help bring down the
blood sugar level the progressive
relaxation we've got into meditation for
15 to 20 minutes creative visualization
having them to to really begin to to we
we had charts showing showing the bhana
and we showed the pancreas so we had to
visualize the pancreas being
restructured and having the cells to
begin to function properly we did again
the rithmatic breathing okay the healthy
fields and they loved that method we
when we did after the program we came
out with a cookbook I cook
the meals that we that we shared with
the people and my former wife she did
all of the cookie which was which was
great because because I also got a
chance to eat you know did have that
fixed though meal so that was great the
instructions and the health emails
preparation each season now one of the
things that that we don't realize this
is that each season our body changes our
digestive changes and so we have to
change some of the foods we eat so we
taught them foods for each season and
with that they did very very well and
then I listened said at the conclusion
of the program they were presented with
the cookbook and we have a manual that
day that they receive matter of fact the
manual has turned into a book that will
be finished publishing probably the end
of next month cuz it's all rigged it's
just being edited connection the letter
got into things like the digestive tract
and let me let me move forward here and
we talked about digestion the mechanics
of it we we talked about the entire
digester structure and why the digestive
digestion is important we talked about
how to chew food we talked about the
fact that what happens when you eat and
you drink at the same time and how
doesn't digest talked about the
different types of the emotions that a
person could be under that would cause
the food not to digest we talked about
nutritional factors we talked about food
combining
I think that's next yeah we talked about
food combining and which foods to
combine how foods actually interact with
each other remember I just said that
it's about chemistry so so we got them
into chemistry and it's and it's amazing
what what happened because people wanted
to learn more they they really met that
when we said that the program was over
that's why they followed us because they
wanted they wanted more information we
talked about digestion the preparation
of foods income in combination
for instance we talked about the factor
of of not in proteins and starches at
the same time you can eat them at the
same meal but don't put them in their
mouth at the same time because if I was
looking for that starts to break down
and the stomach is looking for that
protein and when you get it all mr. Bob
you lady like that what happens is the
body says well what do I do with this
and they send it down into the small
intestines and the small intestines will
say well take this number they go sit in
the corner and I'll call you and then
you have that fermentation and a future
vacation and that methane that starts to
happen in with that sulfate sulfur and
then when it comes out you can't stand
yourself and your friends don't want to
be around you at all and when you drop
it in a bathroom you put a sign on the
door that says please do not enter for
3-4 days
I mean you know some so we we really we
really got to them with that piece and
it's amazing how how many people said
wow you know I ignore the bathroom and
then somebody come in after me and they
don't have to worry about it because of
the fact that we introduced them to eat
healthy eating and how to eat with the
only animals and with the most tell us
supposed to be the most intelligent
animals but we the only animals in God's
kingdom that don't know how to eat
everybody all the other animals eat you
never seen a gorilla pick up a banana in
a state at the same time you see them
you see you see the gorillas pick up a
banana
he'd the banana wait a few minutes then
pick up some leaves you need it but he
but the gorilla doesn't do that but
humans do that we like you said you need
everything you know and being in Chinese
medicine you know in the Asian culture
everything it has a purpose you know I
mean everything has a purpose let's see
where we are okay so this is you have
this in your handout so I really don't
want to go through that but enzymes you
know we taught them about enzyme and we
taught them about the factor that that
enzymes died at 118 degrees Fahrenheit
so that means that we normally cook
stuff at 250 degrees the manufacturers
cook the stuff at five to seven thousand
degrees because they want to make sure
that there's no there's no bacteria and
so by the time it gets to the plate is
dead so we taught them how to how to
cook foods to make sure that the fruits
have enzymes we taught them how to
go about eating raw foods matter of fact
there were some children in the program
that would never eat vegetables by the
end of the program they were eating
vegetables we we taught them about about
the factor of when they feel their body
full of enzymes the body would get well
and when they deplete their body of
enzymes the body don't we get to be sick
and and they'll have problems and that
was part of the diabetes and so we had
them to increase the enzymes we talked
about proteins we educated them very
well on on what proteins do and what
they don't do and why you need proteins
of what kind of proteins that you do
need and which proteins are very more
digestible and which proteins aren't and
we talked about the factor of
lactose-intolerant because you know we
we know that ninety seven percent of
people of color a lactose intolerant and
so when you put something in that your
body doesn't tolerate what does your
body do with it and it'll wind up
sitting in your colon and so then once
it sits in your colon for a while you
might have having what is called the
leaky gut syndrome and the leaky gut
syndrome there will lead to cholesterol
and high blood pressure and diabetes and
and a host of things and and I often say
that that there are no fat people in the
world and people look at me and say well
you've never been fat in your life and
that's the truth
but there's not just a lot of people
that's full of waste because of the
factor that they're suffering from
malnutrition because of malabsorption
and and a malice simulation of the
nutrients from the foods that they eat
and then we talked about carbs and we
talked about how to eat carbs and we did
that through several different methods
we talked about showing people how to
use the glycemic index and then showing
people how to eat carbs that were not
refined and which parts to eat and then
which parts to eat in the summer and the
winter time for instance rice brown rice
well most people be just the same rice
all year long well the truth of the
matter is is that in a winter time you
should be shot grain brown rice because
it has more heat and it works more
effective and in the summer time you
should be eating long grain rice because
in the summer time you don't need as
much as much heat and it's easy of that
to digest so we did that we talked about
how to how to keep things like tabbouleh
those kinds of things which are also
parts of grades and parsley and the
parsley were helped to help to actually
decrease people's own high blood
pressure let's see what else is up today
okay and then we talked about calories
and and and we really showed them how to
identify calories and why was important
to burn certain calories and why not to
eat other calories and the deal with the
fact that things like sugar sugar were
empty calories especially when you have
refined that Domino's sugar that stuff
was was was definitely poison and you
know it's really interesting about sugar
because sugar is legal but it's one of
the biggest drugs and addictive on the
planet because if I asked I asked most
of the people in here how many of you
like sugar
about 85 maybe 90% of he would raise
your hand and what happens is is that
that sugar Rob's our bodies that the B
vitamins will be vitamins are very
needed in in the form for for the help
with diabetes if it helps with
neuropathy those kinds of things so so
so we talked about you know carpets that
they should eat and they should eat and
the glycemic index as I had said we we
taught them about that we talked about
fatty acids because most people when you
say fat they don't they don't realize
that fat is fatty acids and you have you
have two kinds of fatty acids you have
that that you shouldn't eat wood is
saturated fat then you have the probably
unsaturated fatty acids that are that
you shoot that you should be eating but
we also gave them a LA's which is a
lipoic acid we talked about omega-3
omega-6 omega-9 and how they worked in
the body of how the body needs those for
not only lubrication but for hormonal
that help the package to stimulate the
the instrument that kind of things so
weak so we got all been tube into the
biochemistry of the body and then we
talked about a food pyramid and and we
changed a couple of things we we changed
the food pyramid we had interchange the
food pyramid and then we had them
because they were african-americans we
had them to look at the I want to say
glycemic index but it's not the BMI
child and we had to change that because
we did my weight my height and it said
that if I gain five pounds I'd be
overweight and so you know I looked it
you know I mean and and so we we changed
that and we moved it like five and in
some cases ten pounds to see exactly how
that would come and and we did a thing
to to actually work with them
psychologically to get them to realize
that well okay so if you lost this
amount of weight that would put you
under this so then you wouldn't be
overweight and it worked I mean they
really they really got involved in it
and it began to work for them
and then as I talked about eating foods
in their proper seasons all of this all
of this information you have in the
handout okay let's see where we go okay
functional foods and in functional foods
we talked about foods that were that
were good for them to eat like nuts but
but ii think what nuts is is that nuts
it like being and so what next you have
to soak them and that's why that's the
day because I don't like soggy nuts and
you you soak the nuts and then you throw
the water on and you eat the soggy nuts
that's how you get the inhibitors but
I'm not even though sorry nuts forget
about it I will not even else I mean in
Estes it you don't I'll find another way
to get to nutrients that I was gonna die
than us but but we had them we had them
to eat you know healthy foods like we
had them to visit there's a thing called
open water and the recipe for all the
water in it and it works you have
hypoglycemia which you have to have have
a candy bar sugar something that makes
it all the time if you do the oakley
award what happens is you see that just
disappear
because of the chromium in it what what
oatmeal water is is that you take a you
take an 8 ounce glass you take a
tablespoon of steel-cut oats ste EF l
hopes or small or it's not that instant
stuff you can't mess with that okay but
you take that and you put it in a glass
and you had distilled water to it and
put a cover over it and let it sit
overnight in the barn and drink the
water they tell me that the water tastes
good okay what you'll begin to find over
3-4 days you'll begin to find that that
that sugar craving you have just
disappears because you've now begin to
balance your pancreas and and in Chinese
medicine it's the spleen in Chinese
medicine we don't know what the pancreas
we look at the spleen
as the as as where actually Chinese
medicine diabetes is caused by it by the
stomach stomach heat which then reduces
the ability of the pancreas spleen to be
to be dead and so when that happens then
that's why you have thirst and that
controlling factor of the of the spleen
and the stomach on to the kidneys cause
of the Pali Europe so it's a whole lot
different for when we
I looked at we looked at a whole lot of
different dynamics and a lot of that has
to do with we where my background is
from so now we did that we had to do the
impact on food and according to the
Department of Agriculture 40% of the
household budget is spent eating out and
the majority of that is on jumping in
fast food so what we eat that then has
no they have no no treat nutrients in it
was this increase of childhood obesity
and type 2 I mean how many times you see
lines and children with their parents
McDonald's you know I mean or one of
them other places that's fast food so
when you do that you know they're
definitely there's a whole lot of
calories
hold on a stove whole lot of sugar and
no nutrients then in 1992 okay five
percent of the children were had type 2
diabetes how am i doing on time
okay okay somebody some doors skip that
you do have so which foods was created
it now we talk about the vitamins
denatured foods with foreign chemicals
you know in an FDA and the Department of
Agriculture still do not want to admit
that them dyes and preservatives that's
in the food is causing a lot of the
health challenges that were having and
so until we really get investigation on
those foods we we can't officially lead
them to the diseases but if you've taken
any kind of
physiology you would know on that and
you would know that red dye number six
DDT
none of that's originally in your blood
so when your blood gets to become acid
opposed to out of the line then you've
all come up with a whole lot of
different types of of ailments so maca
500 that's a big one I mean we we more
foods that don't have fiber in it did
anything else and it's real interesting
that that people were then gonna get
colon cleanses okay and they don't
realize that the colon cleanse is doing
them dish justice unless you know
opposed to going get some fiber so
that's why we had to do to vote me a
water and eat oatmeal and he brand eat
cabbage he thinks like I'm spinach and
kale because what happened was they
start they saw a great change
lack of enzymes I'm just gonna move
right through these here food labeling
that that was a deep that was it most
deepest part of the program with the
food labeling because people were going
to the store buy some juice and the
juice said 100 percent juice but then it
realized that if they put 10 percent
juice in there to make it say they
didn't have 100 percent juice with
everything else being fillers so what we
had them do was we had to bring in
juices and cans and bottles and that
kind of thing and we showed them where
on the back of the of the of the label
where it said it had 10 to 15% of juice
and everything else is fullest if your
juice doesn't have 85 to 100 percent
juice in it you get enough to buy sugar
and water which is gonna get the
pancreas to fire yeah
pesky fine is gonna wear itself out the
next thing you know your dog is gonna be
giving you some pills because you've got
you've got a diabetes
so we educated them on that and that
went well so then we we did the
supplements and we talked about
supplements and which supplements to
take and why they needed supplements I'm
just going to move right through this
here we had them to drink pure water now
these are the five principles that we
came up with in order to heal from
diabetes and that was choose the right
foods you've got to choose the right
foods because food is our energy without
food we can't move so we have to choose
the right foods and then choose them and
put them in the proper combination
understand that starch starts breaks
down and amount protein breaks down in
the stomach and fats and sugars in the
small intestines when you do that you'll
begin to find that that the foods will
will break down
masticate the food well meaning that if
you chew the food to the truth
who'd is liquid and the bonus that you
create and you swallow it is liquid then
the body's not going to have a hard time
absorbing and assimilating the nutrients
from it take supplements we because of
our food 99.5% of our food is trash we
working on organic but there's an issue
that I see with organic that nobody's
talking about maybe I'm on the wrong
Street which has to be wood
if that organic food is is from
California and it has to get here to New
York then that means that they can't
pick it right they have to pick it in
mature which means that it doesn't have
all the nutrients that it needs again
matter of fact it may be acidic opposed
to being alkaline so now when we begin
to eat foods we have to take supplements
and you don't have to take vitamins and
minerals you can take things like
spirulina we had that one spirulina
spirulina is great for increasing
decreasing the blood sugar level and
increasing the energy we had among
chlorophyll liquid chlorophyll having
taken take an ounce of liquid
chlorophyll a day same thing that
photosynthesis of that liquid
chlorophyll from them plant and and
whole field normally comes from alfalfa
alfalfa's full of nutrients when they
took that what they saw was they saw a
difference in not only collect not only
their blood sugar level their
cholesterol and their blood pressure
because of the fact that that
chlorophylls make chlorophylls
cells have magnesium which works very
well with the hemoglobin or the iron
cell of the blood stream any poor film
not only peripheries but it cleanses the
body that the blood we just about their
suggestions for the protocol you have
this in the arm in the handout let's see
where we are
first they cooperate you have that these
who are finding this ok and you have
that 60 to 90 percent of the people
depression the level
now 315 feet participants lost 40 to 60
pounds cholesterol was it was decreased
20 to 30 percent sixty percent of the
participants hypertension's was
decreased in doctors toasts let several
of participants off of their medicine
because their body began to stabilize
let's see what else we got over here and
that's it right I would say 75% of them
maintaining because we didn't call it a
diet
we call it an eating habit and they saw
the results of them and so when we win
it and check them few of them gave a
little bit of way back but they didn't
revert back to the eating that they were
doing so their blood sugar levels were
still down okay and their hypertension
was what was decreased as well as
cholesterol matter of fact we had a
couple of children who were seven and
eight years old and Nick cholesterol was
off the chain and after them and their
parents going through our program what
happened
the doctor was amazed at the way that
the cholesterol came in
well the program off the top of my head
I think I think for the year for all of
the community I think it was $35,000
that would be that deck might be seven
like maybe a thousand dollars maybe
maybe yeah you know I mean I'm not I'm
not good in that department either but
it's a clinical of good everything but
the number Department but I mean it's
it's it's an affordable program when the
community gets together because you're
talking about fixing food okay you're
talking about making from this we make
sure people have water then we had to
pay folks who work we had some
volunteers but we had to pay face where
the patient might come and do the
exercise actually and we pay one of my
students I did the lecture and then my
former wife she did the cooking okay and
so all of that entail the the amount
that it calls but you know then you're
talking about how many people we had and
at one point in one of the programs we
had 65 people so we were so we was
fixing food for 65 people we had it in a
church and that that church actually
added to church one was one was 54 and
the other one was 65 so it so does
depend on the amount of people that that
come to the
to the program now the thing is is that
that that program can be scaled down to
where you could cut it off stay 10 12 14
20 people that's the limit for this
particular program and then do and then
do them simultaneously
all right they will DC the program did
you find that at all with your clients I
didn't and the reason I didn't was
because we gave them enzymes we had we
had them take enzymes and probiotics
because one of the things that I found
in my study which is which is actually
in my pool that's coming out one of the
things that I found is is that
constipation is a big issue with
diabetes and especially with type 2
diabetics and so if we can get the gut
flora to begin to harmonize with the
bacterias what happens is is that not
only doesn't does it a waste and moving
out of the system but it improves the
overall health of the person and when
they start to take the supplements what
then happens is is that the supplements
then work for them opposed to them
taking them and they're coming out of
their bottom or not working no cramping
there was none of that
no and the end and the interesting thing
is is that people who have flatulence
didn't have it anymore I have a question
for you
just for us to say like most of us
students here
I would say I would say make sure that
that every day that you that you eat
something that's a vegetable three to
four times we eat some green vegetables
okay make sure that if you eat greens
like like kale or something of that
nature you also drink the juice of it
because a lot of the nutrients is going
into the juice that the only functions
call it pot liquor you know so make sure
you drink that eat whole grains and eat
them in season you know like we're
getting ready to go in the spring this
is the time to start to eat long grain
brown rice wild rice okay you want to
eat
Coosh Coosh okay things of that nature
because now you wanted he want to really
begin to to help the body to clean this
is we're getting into the season of the
liver and and in Chinese medicine each
season has a different organ we're
coming out of the season of the kiddies
one of the things I do in my practice
when someone comes in with diabetes
I immediately deal with it with three
organs I deal with the spleen in the
pancreas and the stomach I deal with the
kidneys and I deal with the liver
because all three of those are connected
and when you do that I found that where
I've had nobody in the last 25 years of
dealing with people with diabetes I've
had nobody going dialysis I've had I've
had people's diabetes turned around to
I'm training physicians now how to how
to do that through nutrition if you want
to stay healthy stay awake in that junk
food you know I mean that them soldiers
when you drink that combination with
that with that sugar that's that's
causing calcium
to bind in your system calcium is used
by magnesium well and magnesium you
stelson so if you if the calcium is not
dead the net means that should not gonna
absorb magnesium so if you don't absorb
magnesium vitamin D and vitamin C is not
gonna be be dealt with so then you will
find yourself bruising a lot or you'll
find yourself eating ice because now you
have an iron deficiency so I mean those
are the things and then each one to two
meals a day I ain't one meal a day
that's it I've been doing that for
thirty years and now now for instance
for instance in the morning depending on
what season it is for the winter I eat a
bran muffin and drink water that's the
only thing that I drink and II quit okay
because it's fiber you need if you need
to have that water to lubricate it to
move it out in the spring in the summer
and the fall of eat out or piece of
fruit for lunch a lot of times I don't
eat lunch but I'm out eat dinner so then
it did now fixing vegetables and I have
a brain and then between two four times
a week I'll have some sort of green
vegetable that I eat I don't need
anything frozen or anything out of the
can
metabolism hi and I've heard that a lot
that actually we should do the three
main meals and actually maybe make them
smaller but have six weeks before snacks
all bang on and and and I actually say I
actually say that's not good okay
because it keeps you doing this all day
long so now you get in the habit of
doing that if you eat food and you chew
your food you got to chew it if you chew
your food well you get all the energy
you need all day long if you take for
instance if you get up in the morning
and you make you a glass of spirulina
okay and and some people take the
tablets in and that gotta go through the
digestive tract if you take spirulina
this is what you do you take spirulina
when you eat you take digestive enzymes
you take a balton a good multi mineral
what you'll find is is that you'll find
that you'll have more energy than you've
ever had you'll also find that you won't
be hungry mat fact you have to you have
to force yourself to eat because of the
fact that you won't spirulina has all of
the nutrients we need healthfully store
how did you take it okay but see the
thing that you have to do with that this
is the trick today you could put it in
juice but you have to put it in a
blender so what you do is you take 8
ounces of juice put it in the blender
put the top on it then turn the blender
on take the middle of the of the blender
out on the top
the Ventura then put it in there so that
it mixes okay now you can give me their
for three years in two days trying to
get it to mix but okay and and that's a
good thing
the thing that I say about that is doing
what is in combination with what you're
eating remember always remember that
your chemistry factory and every time
you put something in your mouth that's
like ladies let me let me ask you this
question you go down to one the vendors
you buy you see some nice earrings you
like and you pick them earrings up
they're cheap and you put them areas in
your ear what's gonna happen right you
see you have green stains it'll be
running out of wine because of the
factor that your body's chemistry says
scuse me but I don't think this don't
work with us and it's so the same thing
so the same thing happens when you start
to talk about eating that's like the
clothes that you have on if you wash
them clothes in the wrong type of
detergent you won't get a range and
that's no kid and that's because the
chemistry yes sir
it is nice cream a good supplement for
you know if you not build drinking
calcium oh no I'm on camera sour Sarah
white whether whatever what was in my
head but I would suggest I would suggest
that you not eat ice cream one because
you may be lactose in tongue so if you
like those intolerant then that's gonna
go in your gut and sit there causing
fermentation okay
the the other phrase is that if you're
lactose intolerant the net means that
your body's not going to absorb any
nutrients from them so so what happens
then is again it's it's in your gut okay
that's like soy everybody's big on soy
these days soy is not a food for us that
even lets us fermented it should be it
should be tofu miso necktie or tempeh
that's it but if another milk drinker
you're not getting it in the council
show you are if you drink if you drink
it if you eat greens oranges there's a
whole lot of foods that you can get nuts
you guys so nuts you get you get calcium
from it okay and you know what that
means now the two of you can't drink
that so you know that's what that means
that mean you can't drink that so you
see so so I mean if you take spirulina
you will get council so there's a lot a
lot of substitutes for you to get
calcium you mentioned early above digest
it's one another digestible proteins are
plant proteins okay when when we eat
meat and flush and I'll have no problem
with with folks who consume the EEMA
normal vegetarian and my clients are
Taylor I never discouraged them from
eating meat I tell them that if you're
going to eat it eat meat then you need
an ounce of meat per serving because
what happens is is that you need to try
and get that protein from that meat to
digest in your system so that your body
will function problem but plant protein
is good spirulina I keep going back to
spirulina
three blue algae is you know what I mean
it's it's it's a wonderful thing when I
put people on the fast I have a pleasant
program that we do that that I do every
season and I have people throughout the
country that do it what they do is they
take spirulina and all they no
negativity like they didn't eat three
meals a day because of the fact that
that you're getting your nutrients if we
if we began to take most eat more
seaweed and we began to increase water
pure water like like distilled water
exercise what we would find is we would
find that we would not have illnesses we
have illnesses because
the fact that we leave now no and once
we once we begin to nourish the body
desta Ferber way
from from spirulina spirulina has over
although I take a sublingual supplement
of b12 okay but I don't take it every
day I may take it once a week but I'll
take it but I'll take I'll take
spirulina maybe two three times a week
Ali seaweed so there's other ways of
getting that b12 then now if you have a
digestive tract and the majority of us
said of us do okay you have a digestive
tract and so you figure that you go
again you go get the b12 out of it and
those things from there from from what
you're eating but she's not chewing your
food so if you're not chewing your food
then you stomachs and with this product
okay so then Allah said said said jumps
down into the intestinal tract so you
still like it but when you start to take
when you stop that this is raw food the
spring in the summertime is good to eat
raw food but you have to know what raw
foods to eat in order to get the
nutrients but you but you always need to
put something in there that's gonna give
you the minerals that you need which and
that's that's barley that has been you
know I mean for me it's worth and for my
clients it has really worked you got a
question said yes I will push him my
question is more like a an inquiry what
do you think about okay absolutely
actually talking about deals question
about Africa you know that eat the dirt
which is actually consul cabinet right
so what do you think about that because
in Africa there's really very minimal
questions about osteoporosis or Concha
deficiency yeah I mean you're gonna get
see when you start talking about eating
dirt well that's what we came from it
has minerals long as we don't deplete
the minerals it has it you find people
who hadn't
have a situation called pike are you
familiar with Micah
okay well piped is a vanadium and a
chromium in balance and and years ago
they used to give that to horses when
horses that chewing on the wood they go
to get them in vanadium and chromium but
they wouldn't give it to people and so
when you start talking about that's like
people who do the sea is who used to eat
are the starch you know you dis my child
oh give me a box of that stuff and you'd
be wondering funny that starts have no
idea but it's the same thing but when
you start eating dirt because some
people from the south they directly okay
which means that the dirt is giving them
the nutrients that they need that's why
you don't find a deficiency especially
in the in a country as rich as Africa
long as they don't
thank you a wonderful day my information
is on the information on it if you need
to you can email me if you email me I'll
let you know when the book comes out and
if you decide to invite me back to New
York not enjoy it make sure it's not the
weather though you know I mean today's a
nice day even though I grew up in
Massachusetts but today is it nicely but
you know I just I come into wintertime I
just had to put on a few extra thank you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes tc
Columbia edu